have to ask you about working
with elizabeth shu speaking of
expectations
i mean she's one of the biggest
returnees that fans were anticipating so
you find out that happens are there any
nerves to jumping into that kind of
material or are you excited to
absolutely i think that once again you
you're working in this universe
and i'm used to it now working with
ralph and working with billy and working
out and slapping martin
um but elizabeth shoe is kind of the
missing link
to to this universe that we've created
and
she's so important to so many fans and
to me i was a huge karate kid fan like
she's important to me
and so i'm just like oh god and
everybody's like you're not ally where's
ally here and you're amanda's not ally
i'm like i know
so i'm like she's heightened to me um
she was so nice so lovely that
immediately i was like
oh this is good until i'm sitting across
the table from all three of them it's
elizabeth you it's billy zapkins ralph
macchio and i'm just like there's
there's like a nine-year-old inside me
being like this isn't normal like
whatever's happening right now you're
gonna have to process later just to get
through this scene but like this is
you're having like a fantasy right now
the cool thing about that scene too is
anyone out there who's like you're not
ally now that scene kind of gives even
more meaning to that in a sense like
when she's
when she sends them on their way out the
door it's like
them leaving her behind only enhances
the relationship that they have
i think so i think they handled it very
sweetly i think that they did a very
good job of like
introducing her back and bringing her in
and like giving her such a warm
fun scenes to have but also being like
but that was high school and we are
and this is where we are now and we're
growing i'm hoping
so her return has a big effect on the
two of them but i'm curious because
amanda's always been a very effective uh
mediator of sorts between the two guys
so after having this conversation with
ali
is there a new i i guess a tool in her
toolkit so to speak that she can then
apply
to mediating for them and you know the
inevitable arguments they're going to
have running miyagido together
i think i think absolutely because as
far as amanda's concerned
obviously things get more and more
aggressive as these seasons are going on
and she's recognizing how dangerous
you know john crease is um but as far as
she's you know this karate
this just boring karate dojos that these
these two have she's kind of like this
is
you guys are kind of bonkers like this
is high school and i think
bringing ali back and her being like oh
yeah no they're they're
they're cookies and we're like oh yeah
yeah
i'm not the only one who sees this i
think that's very helpful to have
someone like ali on her side well job
well done again
love the new season you are fantastic in
it thank you so much for your time today
thank you so much